good evening Mr sugar said The Man
Behind The Desk whose job it was to
never forget a face
sugar was 41 years old unmarried and
Rich strange the following is what Henry
read in the little blue exercise book
I'm a man who can see without using his
eyes
I cried he saw that trolley this is
absolutely unbelievable
I was flabbergasted this is a terrific
piece of information this could change
my life it's an extraordinary thing
happened all at once he sees through his
own skin like an x-ray only better he
sees everything Penny was now almost
certainly capable of making money faster
than any other person in the entire
world
interesting
[Music]
his name was Henry sugar I think people
ought to know a bit about what he has
done for the world
[Laughter]
[Music]